I got the blues the TV blues I got the
heebie-jeebies EV blue
feeling low down way down low down tired
of my long time slow down waiting for
that special day when the doc can say be
on your way I got my baby
it in time to spend but time drags on
when there is no way
blue and lowdown way way down low down
even for that knockout showdown building
to that special day when the doc can say
be on your way
hello doc hello bill how you doing Oh
fine just great what's wrong something
bothering you you ought to know this by
heart now I want to get my clothes get
out of here whoa is that all oh you've
heard all this before I still want to
get married have a family for the living
bill you will be able to do all of those
things I've told you that before yeah
but when do I start you've started
already you started the day you came
here seem like a long time didn't like
years instead of weeks remember all the
examinations we gave you all the tests
we made they showed how sick you really
were they showed things nobody could
know just from looking at you suspicious
shadows in your lungs
and in your sputum germs tbj they didn't
just happen you've got them by direct
contact with someone who already had
tuberculosis
or maybe you got them by contact with
objects infected by someone with
tuberculosis you could pass those germs
on to someone else your family for
instance if you had been at home
when the Germans first appear there may
be only a few and usually a healthy body
will wall the men or kill them but
sometimes there are too many germs for
the body to overcome you may become
rundown
from too much physical activity too much
work too much play
not enough rest to the proper food then
the germs multiply
you're sick
there's no medicine that by itself is a
sure thing to cure you to get well you
must have rest proper food and medical
care to get well you must be careful to
limit the things you do until we know
what and how much you can do safely it
helps to be reminded gosh I want to get
well and stay well you may feel well but
the examinations and x-rays tell us
you're still sick you've improved but
you still have to stay in bed and rest I
am resting I not so sure that you don't
seem able to relax you move about too
much and that means you're working
working what do you mean anything that
isn't rest is work ever do much in
sports
or did you ever stay up late playing
cards remember how tired you got play is
work any activity is work even walking
or study
bill many patients simply don't
understand what we mean by work too
often they leave the hospital too soon
do too much and break down remember
charlie james yeah here he's back that's
right it wasn't many months ago Charlie
decided there was no keeping him in the
hospital he thought he could take it
easy at home and he did for a while he
had no regular job but he soon found
himself playing the kids you know how it
is at home it's hard to sit around not
do anything that's what happened to
Charlie he got busy without knowing it
even began getting to bed early he
didn't realize it was all adding up to
too much work for him
in fact he just didn't know how much he
was doing or could do so Charlie's back
again
back where you were when you first came
here at that time you remember you
didn't do anything but rest and yet you
were tired all the time but gradually
you got stronger until you could read
right get out of bed for your meals and
go to the bathroom as you get stronger
will allow you to do more work more yeah
but what does it all get me just this
you're getting well we know now that you
can get well but it's a gradual process
at the rate you've been improving we
should be moving you soon as a semi
ambulant patient you'll be able to get
around a bit do more to take care of
yourself
you have full bathroom privileges and be
allowed more recreational activity to
maybe you want to hear some music play
there are lots of things you
of course being sick does have its rough
spots and tuberculosis often produces
some tough personal problems
but there are always ways to work them
out and you go about it right and the
social worker will give you expert
guidance based on experience and the
handling of problems just like yours of
course you can read or even study if you
want it the educational therapist is
always available for extra help the
occupational therapist will give you
simple work tasks depending on your
treatment needs you'll be expected to
spend a prescribed amount of time each
day in this activity none of these
simple tasks will train you for a job
but they will show you and show us our
work agrees with you your progress will
be followed carefully in a number of
ways by means of x-ray children's
variety of laboratory tests
these will be made as often as necessary
to show us just how well you were doing
under the treatments you are getting
when your disease has become stabilized
you will be permitted still more
activity you'll be able to leave the
ward go to the main dining room for your
needs
with the other ambulance agents
you'll get a deep satisfaction out of
doing some of the simple things you've
been denied so long
you'll find yourself walking more you'll
feel you're beginning to live again you
yourself will realize you're able to do
move but always based on a day of
balanced activity you'll think about
work a job after you leave and you can
get help and planning for it
some fellows make mistake of not
planning Tom Baylor for instance used to
be one of my patients he couldn't be
bothered about planning or training he
wasted his time he heard the future take
care of itself the soft high-paid job
just fall into West but it didn't work
out that way Tom couldn't make the grade
no training no experience so he wound up
as a laborer on a construction job
he couldn't take now he's back worse
often before we could have helped him
plan for training and work he could do
but he wouldn't listen however most of
our patients do listen they know our
program of gradually increased activity
is prescribed medically according to
each patient's progress they know it
will get them to the point where their
plan will begin to pay off most of them
listen to us are you listening are you
listening
well doc what's the good word you've
come a long way bill there are fully
ambulant patient as of right now you
once told me you wanted to earn a living
when you got out right right can you get
a job and stay well I think so but do
you know well not exactly well no one
knows yet but we can help you find out
if you stick with us for we have the
facilities to do it shops and classrooms
where our patients to complete their
treatment to help us find out how much
work they can do many of them are
planning to work at a trade work with
their hands make things
others are planning for a profession
but no matter what they plan to do to
earn a living a wide variety of
facilities is available to enable the
patience to find out for themselves rock
and how much they can do
and this variety too in the amount of
time they spend here each day these two
men are working on the same project Hank
will complete his in about five days but
Jim will have to spend two weeks to do
the same thing why we allow gym to work
only two hours a day now but we have
found that Hank can work four hours a
day each of these patients works on an
individual time schedule the amount of
time each one spends here is prescribed
we keep a constant check on condition
and progress and allow them to work more
only when they can do so without
becoming too tired
many want to keep on working even after
their time is up but they learn quickly
that their work is adjusted to give them
a proper balance of daily activity the
work done here is not intended to Train
anyone for a particular job it's to find
out the patient's ability to perform and
physical capacity to perform this
applies to every type of endeavor Frank
Lorenzo for example wants to do some
sort of work in machinist field he made
his plans with the help of vocational
guidance his expressed interest in
mechanical work was borne out by tests
for aptitude and interest they
demonstrated that Frank had good
coordination he chose his field and his
records showed us that he could enter so
we put him on light mechanics
he's doing many different things that
require precision and the use of a great
variety of precision instruments his
work involves bending reaching lifting
and because the title job he wants will
include such things we know the demands
of such jobs and we schedule his
activities so he can approximate those
demands now what Frank does here will
not train him for any particular job but
he will be able to choose any one of
many and machinists feel he will go out
to school or on the job training and
will know he can learn and do exactly
what they teach it it can become a
machinist get a job live a full life
Hugh Fleming plans to be a chemical
engineer
his scores and the tests we gave him
indicated special aptitude for math when
he came to rehabilitation we started him
in two classes solid geometry and
english an hour a day for each now he
studies three hours a day and helps in
the hospital lab two hours a day working
toward credit in the school he plans to
enter when he leaves us
this sort of classroom work study and
shop work are only part of a day's
activities they take up only a few hours
and during the other hours of the day
there's rest and self-care and there's
still another sort of work sort of thing
that rounds out of normal day for
anybody play recreation fun whatever you
want to call it and whatever form it
takes it's needed in the right
proportion to balance a day's activities
it all adds up to a fuller life all
these activities are part of a plan
program carried out here not to help
build you up to that day we be
discharged in your own
a day you will leave knowing you're well
again that you can choose your own work
and be sure you can do
the day you can go home for good that
day will come for you bill did you wait
you make it pretty tough for me in a way
you know I want to leave here right now
don't you sure I know you know they're
waiting for me back home we've all
waited a long time I know well I guess
we'll just have to wait a little longer
but it'll be worth it won't it well so
long doc been nice seeing you you look
in this healthy as can be you're a
strong as a rock and I want you to know
that's just what I want to be healthy
that's just what I want to be gonna lick
TV if it's the last thing I do I'll do
whatever you say gonna lick TV doc tell
me what to do I'd like to go home but I
will stay if you say so like to go home
but I will stay
I got a little girl she's awaiting for
me so is my family oh I ain't too smart
but there's more things I know KOTD doc
hey yo TV oh I won't get low and I won't
be blue I'll do whatever you say gonna
lick TV doc tell me what to do I'd like
to go home but I will stay if you say so
like to go home but I will stay yes I'd
like to go home but I will stay doc like
to go home but I will stay